[Musique]
aujourd'hui Gabrielle avait lieu à
plaisir une première journée
départemental des réussites éducatives
des ivelines en quoi ça consistait et
bien oui une journée organisée par
l'académie de Versailles et la
préfecture des ivelin l'objectif
grégoryi de cette journée faire
rencontrer les différents acteurs de
l'éducation du département afin de
penser l'école de demain alors plusieurs
tablrondes étaient organisé sur
différentes thématiques comme construire
et entretenir les lien avec les parents
ou encore accompagner la réussite de
tous les jeunes un moment privilégié de
rencontrre et d'échange pour les acteurs
de l'éducation on les écoute nous
croyons beaucoup dans l'alliance
éducative de tous les acteurs au service
des enfants qu'il relève de l'éducation
nationale de la préfecture des communes
nous nous voyons très fréquemment dans
les quartiers pour dans le cadre des
cités éducatives dans le cadre des
programmes de réussite éducative bref
dans le cadre de divers dispositifs mais
c'était important d'avoir ce temps
départemental pour rassembler tous tous
tous ces ur de l'éducation l'intérêt
c'est d'avoir aussi une vision globale
comment intervenir de façon globale et
de structurer ces outils et c'est pour
cela qu'on a développé autour des
programmes de r éducative aussi la la
logique de cité éducative qui est un
dispositif d'intégration qui réunit
autour de la table tous les acteurs
éducation nationale collectivité locale
association qui interviennent autour
dans le temps scolaire et autour du
temps scolaire vers les enfants vers les
élèves alors journé également de
rencontes de discussion cette fois-ci au
Vélodrome national de C en Yveline et
c'était sur la thématique du sport avec
l'UVSQ l'université de Versailles squant
en yeline qui organisait son 5e et
dernier symposium sport santé oui et
pour l'occasion grégoryi l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yveline
avait réuni sa communauté universitaire
mais aussi le grand public au programme
conférence et table ronde sur la
thématique sport et santé des étudiants
mais aussi des activités de découverte
des disciplines olympiques comme le BMX
ou encore le breakdce à l'approche des
Jeux de Paris 2024 cette journée était
placée sous le signe de l'olympisme
l'événement se terminera avec la
traditionnelle cérémonie d'vœux du
président de l'vsq et vous pourrez
retrouver un reportage complet sur cet
événement dans le prochain numéro du
skycho on va prendre des nouvelles des
bus dans le sudiveline on avait mis en
lumière ces dysfonctionnements
concernant le service des bus transdèv
autour des communes de chevreus et de
Lévis Saint-Non est-ce que la situation
s'est améliorée et bien oui pour pour
rappel he depuis début janvier la date
de reprise du transporteur Transdev le
le service des bus est fortement
perturbé parmi les problématiques on le
rappelle grégoryi des arrêts non
desservis mettant en difficulté les
collégiens et donnant lieu à des
situations parfois absurdes comme
lorsque certains maires des communes
touchées s'improvisent taxis pour les
élèves face à la colère des élus Valérie
pcres présidente d'île-de-fance mobilité
a annoncé la mise en demeure de Transdev
dénonçant une situation inacceptable
elle demande au transporteurs le respect
du contrat sous peine d'un retrait de la
délégation du service public selon nos
confrères de cette suite actu on termine
avec une information qui concerne le
festival Electric Park à Chatou oui
attention si vous aviez pris vos places
pour l'édition 2024 vous allez devoir
revoir votre organisation en raison des
Jeux Olympiques et paralympique la
programmation et la date de l'événement
doit changer si le festival était
programmé cette année les 30 et 31 août
2024 il se tiendra finalement sur une
seule journée et ce sera le 15 juin
prochain ce changement et suite à une
décision tardife du préfet de police de
Paris qui a demandé aux organisateurs de
changer la date du festival pour des
raisons de sécurité à noté tout de même
grégoryi que les passes de jours seront
bien évidemment remboursé merci beaucoup
Gabriel et si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoins d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les evelines
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news